I have never met an everyday casual
coming back from their 9 to-5 job
cigarette smoker that are using utane
torches to light their cigarettes dude
if it's drugs bro you can give me 10
extra charges bro I won't say nothing
turn the body cans off not how that
works you're not going to send me back
to federal prison right now dude for
nothing dog help me bro help me bro help
me bro push push push bro your
[Music]
Fe
dispatch has been
upated window
down hands what are you doing keep them
up keep them
up hop on out the car man hop out y step
out got any weapons on you why am I
getting to out the car cuz you didn't
stop way back when you were lit
uping don't face the car where's the
knife at uh left or right I'm not sure
okay you mind if I take it out you sure
go ahead on going H I apologize I was
just listening to music I didn't even
know you guys i'
seen going to put all this stuff right
here
okay
this is why I could hear you sir you
didn't have that on yes I I just drove
by you we locked eyes there was I play
all day long all I
heard I was right next to you with my
window down yelling at the lady on the
bike I was right we were right here you
went this way I was right there with my
window down yelling at the lady on the
bike I your sound system was so loud
that you couldn't hear our Sirens
directly behind you no I seen you that's
BS when I got I was just when I go pass
you guys I respect you have
[Music]
okay want to tell me what this is going
to be uh that's uh uh bag bom my dog's
got
bag and the
body I'll put it in
why does it stink like
weed you smoke earlier n my body smokes
weed my car SM got can't smoke in a
car
console bro you see what I'm talking
about nope it's in a it's in a pack they
sell them at the store it's in like a
zipper pack
[Music]
C found your scale in there
though
what are you doing with them I was just
asking me about some music and shit I my
music up sh my up I don't
know so it looks like what I saw like
you either gave her something or she
gave
oh I gave oh I gave her some change you
go there and get some ice with
the some change I don't
know Mar 12 you C yourself off probably
got
you I'm sorry I'm confused put the phone
down sorry what are you doing I'm
confused that that cream's for your dog
yeah well it's it's for horses and cows
but it's like an antibiotic L it's got
like steroid in it that's weird why
would it pop hot for marijuana
dude it's for THC oil bro it's it's B
bomb bro well you see that color right
there that's a beautiful blue what does
blue mean marijuana THC
smell your ointment that I don't know
what it what it is it's bad bomb bro I
put it on my dog nuts bro he's got a
fuck from chewing his shit put it on
another tester bro
T why I li to
you
ja right now
[Music]
okay put your hands like a pray yes
that's not how you
pray you got anything hidden in your
pants now it's time to tell me no sir
I really
[Music]
wide
bro I'm
Hur didn't say to split bro I'm sorry
you sa me a wi bro I'm not trying to
give you no problem dude I ain't lying
to you about
nothing it's my dog ball bro it's the
stuff they use for the
[Music]
cows your take your hands off your back
PS so what I'm going to do I'll put on a
second test
kit just to humor you br it's not right
in front of you if it pops out from
marijuana again you're going to jail can
you follow you the chair I don't need
to smell it man I put it on my what is
smells like makes no damn difference to
me no if it's weed BR smell like weed
smell not unless it's oil unless it's
it's it's antibiotic trip and smell it
bro we're going to do it together right
here dude just smell it h that might not
be saying is right bro it's got It's got
numbing in it it's got stuff that helps
you heal dude it's got a big you know
what make it helpful is if you kept it
in the proper container instead of a
bull old peill container I mean I I
somebody gave it to you me bro want to
give me a whole
can see bro I told you it's not done
here in a minute I just do a chical
reaction wow it's starting to turn blue
already come on man this antibiotic me
bro I'm not going lie you about that DB
man that's dumb I wouldn't do that to
you bro oh look it's getting more
blue that is not
drugs antibiotic my dogs not
sorry if I don't believe
you dude smell it two and a half three
blocks to pull over first dude that's my
fault I was listening to music bro I
apologize you're meeting up with two
users and dealers in the county after a
hand toand exchange of some kind that
we're not even going to get into no I
don't do drugs man you have a scale in
your center console you got butane
torches that are typically used out here
to cook methampetamine and heroin
because people aren't lighting their
goddamn cigarettes with a 6in butane
torch I don't and then you got bags full
of blue testing positive THC you're
painting me a bad picture dude it's not
federal pration I piss every week I
don't do drugs I don't do drugs I don't
off I don't get high I got friends that
do but guess what wild you know what I
I've been I've been talking a brick ball
and everything bro I work is on
suspension I don't want to hear a name
drop on yeah what happened to that so
looks like you're going to be placed
under arrest please don't violate my
probation for something dude just smell
it bro what difference does that make
because I'm telling you on on god dude
that's what it is I'm not lying to you
right put it on God man dude I see it
man I put it on God and unborn children
dude just smell it man it's an ointment
bro I swear I'm not this isn't the only
charge better to comply when we light
you up blue light blocks ago please
that's another charge you what do you
want my help I don't need your help
please man help you have nothing to
offer me please don't take me ja Shir
I'm working hard I'm at spelling off man
dude dude don't take me to time for this
man please please man I'm moving my
house right now my camper and everything
please don't take me to jail it's not
drugs man I don't know tell you tell me
it's drugs please dude you can call
somebody over here that's a knows
something brother they're going to show
you that it's not drugs
man what please dude it's not drugs dude
I'm not lying to you dude if it's drugs
bro you can give me 10 extra charges bro
I won't say nothing turn the body cans
off it's not how that works bro it's not
bro
weird I don't know bro it's got num gave
that to my
mom call my mom bro and ask my mom what
she what she gave it to me and bro I
ain't got on the phone and said nothing
please at least do that bro my mom's a
retired government employee dude she
worked at Flagger County Courthouse
please dude she's the one that they sent
me dude I dude I can't fuck Pi it
up please bro dude I'm not you she gave
me that shit for my nuts
man it wouldn't be nice is if you had it
in a proper container yes sir know with
a label on it describing what it is and
what it should look like and the texture
of it right now you got a ripped up pill
bottle full of oil that's testing
positive for hash it's not man it's
pointment bro pointment man call my
mother right there you hit mom what are
you on for counterfeit money I got C
some counterfeit money I do tattoos
somebody bro that's a mixture of
what the not say hot
profeel what I'm saying you know what's
weird I got a tip off that that chick
was going to be attempting to purchase
fentanyl today dude look at dude it's
fucking it's it's triple antibiotic just
smell it man oh yeah I'm going to sniff
your trip antibiotic I put call my mom
my mom die right supposed to be if it
turns this color it's fat all if it
turns purple it's heroin all right it's
really easy color coding so how the can
it be all these different things
dude bro
dude
science
chemistry mother my mother she died out
of a
from Mi something no it's not bro just
call my mother would you at least give
me that fucking just call my mother just
so you can clarification that she gave
me some Bag bomb for my dog's
balls bottle bro I can't make that up I
can't call her and tell her say that huh
have no no maybe it didn't I'm telling
you you J chist here we
go why would I lie to you dude is it's
right there in your face you can send it
you send it to the lab you're going to
know I'm lying to you the rest of my
life you send it to the lab and it comes
back BR it's not drugs man please bro
send it and paper I'll report to you
whenever it comes back please man I
don't I don't do drugs it's not drugs D
it's not drugs bro I at this time you
are probably you're going to jail for
for what pleas comply the law we signal
in Siren for you to stop blocks ago
please I just came home why did you do
this possession fatl possession uh
marijuana dude that's not F man that's
what the test is for
dude dude man please don't to the lab
and they'll come back and tell us I'm
going to buy it bro I put it on god dude
that's my dog's ball ointment man call
my mother please at least give me the
appucation either way you're going to
jail you know that right why for failure
to comply with the lawful order we
signaled in Siren for you to stop
forever
[Applause]
ago you know how many cigarette smokers
I deal with every day you know how many
legitimate everyday normal cigarette
smokers use a butane torch my hands
nothing when you smoke you you see two
fingers yeah see the difference on
them look like two fingers bro no but
they yell smoking cigarettes bro okay
you could smoke cigarettes and M or
heroin you can do both I have never met
an everyday casual coming back from
their 9o5 job cigarette smoker that is
using Dain torches to light their
cigarettes no never I don't I got I got
one now every time I run into somebody
that I have meth pipes bubbles heroin
spoons all that they always have butane
torches I'm not saying it's illegal to
own a butane Tor I'm just saying there's
a prance of things here that leads me to
believe that there's more going on than
you want to let me know okay I'll tell
you whatever you want to know I don't
want to know anything I'm telling you
the whole truth nothing there is nothing
I want to know I'm not trying to be a
dick but I I don't I I don't do the n
shit I don't care I'm not ning bro I'm
just telling you as a manager take my
glasses off please I don't I don't even
want to touch you you're sweating like a
dog listen bro listen
listen bro been in this fucking County
my whole
life I'm I came home with federal
probation I do I look I work with my
brother we got painting business I'm
coming over here to see my Uncle ashes
and fucking espol fucking Park bro I
don't do I don't do drugs I don't do WR
please bro please SC my life dud don't
ruin it like this bro if I did something
wrong man I like I'm sorry I didn't pull
over man I'm sorry dude I was listening
to music I'm enjoying life dude you're a
bad dude I think you do dumb things that
was I get if I would have seen look look
at my back window bro I I I can't see
out of it bro that's proba why they have
tent LW I'm sorry man do it on purpose
bro I don't nothing wrong right but
that's o BR I promise if it's an
ointment the charge drop it doesn't
matter my violation we still go through
I got to go through all please don't do
that to me man I don't want to tell you
I'm not taking the chance that's like 10
G of who is Y super okay I didn't want
that's like 10 grams of weight then if
it comes back as a heroin fentanyl
whatever mixture T not happening on your
kids bro it's not and then I come back
to find you you think you're just going
to walk down the door guess you're right
I'll do my 20 years dude it's not drugs
bro I don't know man I promise you on
your kids your kids and God's kids man
God's children BR up this world bro
that's not drugs man not
want God bro it's not drugs bro please
dude just hang out then wait if you ever
believed anybody in your life D believe
me bro
it's aren you going to be able to find
out for sure 100% And then you're going
to be like dude I wish I wouldn't have
done that dude's life like that man
please don't do it you're going to see
you got to Hon in front of you if I'm
wrong I'll say hey man
bro I you will I think you're going to
save your ass cuz that's not just time
right there dude I told on myself PL I
don't do fucking hugs man the one thing
I pride myself in is I don't get high no
more man that's it I smoke my little
fake little taste like just because you
don't get high doesn't mean you're not
out here selling something bro look at
my pocket then you run into two people
that are users and dealers and I already
had a tip from earlier today that she's
tweaking and hurting because she can't
get her product and to keep an eye on
her because she's going to try and pick
up something today next thing I know you
two are in a parking lot there's a quick
hand in hand if you're giving her money
I don't know I didn't see what you gave
and then we stop you you don't stop and
then I find this you want to know
exactly I'm like this how you'll know
I'm fucking telling you the truth the
girl asked me for 50 Cent and I gave her
a fucking 50 Cent In nickel bro out of
my center console have one of them
Police pull it over bro and she going to
see I'm not telling no be able to find
her what she's a Drifter she'll probably
drift right by this motherfucker kid she
drift by 20
years
passing multiple places that you could
pull over safely you want to know why
you want to know why want to know why
cuz I'm a dumb ass just want people to
steal my system my spray paint in my
back window bro how are they going to
steal your
system I'm not I'm talking about I'm not
here now I'm talking about stuff like
that paint my back window seconds some
Sirens look bro I got hit by look at my
mirrors man look look I got a mirror
taped on I don't have one on the other
side and this is why we have traffic
laws that say you're not allowed to do
that St stupid shit because now you get
jammed up in these situations I got hit
by a deer on like door I just fixed that
side of the car you might as well spray
paint your windows black and drive
around and not and be surprised when you
get in the craft no I understand I Wrong
Way D that's the worst thing I've
fucking done right now bro I I got I
bought one beer burs in my seat I
haven't even drank a fucking sh are you
even allowed to have alcohol yeah we're
allowed to have alcohol we just can't
drink for ass B are different fuck my
life up bud tell you guys on the stre
man long and shorter I had to the dog
please the dog is not going to change
anything all that that does not confirm
narcotics that that confirm you hit on
your car it smells like we are oh my God
so that's all that's going to happen
there the dog is not I told him my buddy
smokes me in my car and listens to my
music cuz I got music he got fucking
weed C bro that's great doesn't mean he
can smoke it in your car what do you
mean that's not me smoke in the car man
listen toe I'm going to look at you guys
all please man look please man please
man why is this happening to me I do
something wrong to somebody else bro I
do not have drugs as my mom gave me
please
man please bro I can't bro will you get
medical for me bro please I can't do
this dud you I'm freaking out right now
please hold up
please please bro I'm scared bro dude I
got
psychological man bro I'm unmedicated
bro I'm telling you I'm take medication
please call my federal probation officer
D please Mani but as
right nobody's going to answer the phone
on I don't do drugs I don't have drugs
on me pleaseing to the test test again
prove yourself that you're
fucking man it's not going to let me
down dud not fucking drugs man you have
bad test bro want
to experience I'm so scared D I didn't
do that that's not J going be your last
oh my
God I want to kill myself dude
[Music]
I I have chares I didn't
do you're
going you have
chares let me get air won't move
no please let me stay here dude call
Medical please longer we delay this bro
I'm just delayed dude I didn't do
nothing not going to transport you I
know I need to see bro my chest hurts
you please
bro please dude just trust me I'm not
lying you dude I'm not a fucking liar
dude you're seeing me like this bro I
wasn't like this when you guys got me
pull pull me over bro this is so Sur
Real dude I didn't do nothing wrong bro
I thought it was going to be a r traic
stop he got me out in the car I was
fucking like who what's going on dude
there's nothing bad in my
car please can you grab me another one
of the wats man
please do something you don't do say
your pain bro you're a smart man bro
don't chug it like you did don't you
dude you could be like you could answer
your own question right just kid telling
the truth can't break the law sir I
can't do that you can H it bro as of
right
now you got to do smell it and you'll
know I'm not lying
dude oh my God you on bro if you smell
it you you know you me my life doesn't
get ruined man to you just so you're
aware we have people conceal things and
everything you I know take risk of I
don't know you used to be one of those
people so I don't know maybe the same
person that was smoking we in your call
I've been using now I've been using that
for my dog nobody's fing going he's not
going to go in there put fit on there
that's crazy dude smell this you want
some water yes sir here take a breath
stop talking for 10 seconds you guys are
making the biggest mistake in your life
man you're I'm man you're being a good
man bro CH 10 seconds and relax okay CH
oh stop stop stop talking just stop just
breathe just stop and breathe for 10
seconds man bab if I was wrong I just
going get
man I just want you to help me bro I'm
not freaking out for nothing these
people are Li people are liars deceivers
they lie to you guys and they fucking
play with you guys I fucking voluntarily
call fucking law enforcement bro to try
and help get fucking fit and all off the
streets bro my baby mama die because of
it call you can call Brick while he's on
vacation suspension for the shit at fins
I know bro I fucking please dude please
man I fucking work I don't I
will you help me man please dude what I
need you to do hold on hold on give me
the water bottle please I need you to
take 10 seconds before you chug it all
right cuz you're you down it in 5
seconds like you did last time it's not
going to help anything you're sitting
next to a hot car because it's kicking
out heat it's not helping you so you
need to take a breath Mr Chris we're not
going to talk to you for 10 seconds all
right so just sit here for 10 seconds
all right you want to go to jail or
something it's not real I you don't but
you're still talking you're still
talking it's not real man I'm a man bre
for 10 seconds I'm looking at I'm a man
you can look at me for 10 seconds I
don't care as long as you stop talking
I'm a man besides that uniform you're
wearing I a man and I'm not fucking
lying to you please do it as a man and
smell it and know I'm fucking that's not
going to tell us anything you know what
anot triple anot it's the same thing bro
can please dude you saved my life man
please you can't do this to me man it's
you're going to kill me bro my dude I
fucking spent 15 years I'm hfo dude you
guys are putting me in jail for some
ointment man please just put some real
drugs out of your pocket in there and
something don't fucking make me go sit
in jail knowing I'm in jail over
ointment bro pleas don't carry drug
around dude huh we don't just carry
drugs around bro please do something
don't fucking I'm a psych patient dude
and I sit in there and I can't believe
the system failed me bro and I worked
hard for it this time dude I need to
take I sat down with every fucking
detective homicide detectives everybody
in this fucking FY jail dude when I went
to the Federal and I asked him to come
and talk to me and I helped him dude I
fucking want this shit that fucking shit
is killing people needs to be off the
fucking Street dude all right CHR 10
seconds you guys are fucking doing this
to me stop talking man just free just
free just for 10 seconds we're not going
anywhere just free don't hurt me bro
nobody's hurting
you
myom just
call ask the question d you do
nothing that's godamn ointment man
please call somebody out here to help me
bro you're not going to fucking s me
back to federal prison right now D for
nothing
dogs are going to violate you for
ointment if it comes back as o I don't
foresee them violating you bro I got to
go through this system dude the federal
system is six fucking months bro I lose
my car my fucking the trailer everything
dude and I'm not doing nothing wrong you
can go look at my trailer bro you want
to go look at my trailer dude you're
still talking man please bro help me man
I don't fucking do nothing
wrong you guys got a you got a o on
you're taking me to jail don't do that
to me man
pleas please bro please please please
man you guys
I fucking you guys please you got to
fucking just know in your heart dude you
one of you guys has got the fucking
instinct to know that somebody's telling
the truth man when you guys please help
me bro please dude I'm not lying man on
my fucking mother dude oh my God God
strike my mother dead right now dude I
feel Ling please man please save me God
sa me you don't let this happen to me
man I didn't do nothing
wrong
Please Mr low Mr low you some pipe of
others assessment there's no way you're
just not going to believe anything I'm
saying
man dude it's two different name test BR
send it inconclusive send it to the lab
and spare my
life spare my you're going to you're
making a mistake
dude the siso that fucking test is dude
that's B bomb man
I put it on everything man you're making
a mistake bro I swear when you sent it
to the lab like damn we fucking sit that
dude pris you fucking cry dude told us
the truth man please bro I would never
let I live in this County for 35 years
I'll have to deal with you guys for the
rest of my life man you're going to
fucking tell me man Heath man I ain't
going to tell you I'm sorry cuz I did my
job but my bad man please bro fucking
promise you on everything not fucking
fug dude I'm I was just lay out and get
in the cop car go to jail dude it's
going to go to the lab and I'm going to
go jail anyway bro what's the difference
it's not J don't make me go to jail for
nothing is what I'm saying
manbody on the possibility that somebody
was wrong nobody would ever go to jail
everybody tell I'm stuck here you guys
can fuck me over bro I'm not lying notal
but you just it's not it's not your goal
I'm not say please don't take this the
wrong way I'm not saying that you guys
are doing it right now I'm getting
fucked over by those test kits right now
bro it's not drugs man please dude give
me the benefit of the give yourself the
benefit of the doubt dude I am stuck
here I'm on federal
probation I've never seen incorrect Tes
I've never even seen a fit in all Tes or
any of that shit in my life dude I just
did I have I I don't know bro it's not
drug I fucking promise you you bro I
hope I hope when the lab gets it then it
comes back so what are you going to do
with my live stream in B comes back in
the lab dude you're going to see me on
the fucking Street on a bicycle dude
fucking say my bad bro there's nothing I
can do
as as it is to in possession no I'm not
in possession of that that's not my
car now it's not your car it's my stuff
that's my ointment bro my mom gave it to
me for my dog but it's not my car it's
my mom's car bro you're going to make me
lose my car my life over said it's not
your car it's my mom's car man she it's
my mom the mom candy Lee Heath that's
the tag that's my mom I got good
driver's license I do everything I'm
supposed to do bitch who drives I drive
it bro okay you're the only one that
drives it yeah the insurance in my the
insance I'm in the I'm on the policy
Please Mr you're the only one that
drives it and that was found in the car
yes and you have said conclusively
definitively you're the one that used
the ointment to put on your dog yes bro
yes it's what it is okay so then you are
in possession dude it's not drugs man
okay but it's testing positive can I I
just want to stand up I'm dizzy hold on
can I just lean right here you're dizzy
prob don't want to stand up I got to
broke a car look at my bone bro look at
my Caroll bone bro I just broke a month
and about maybe a month or 3 weeks ago
most mon going to have on a fucking dirt
bike bro I'm hurting right now I need to
stand up straight now please man I'm
fucking dying you guys why would
you C dud what the fuck did I do wrong
in life to get sh like this
man oh
my I I know bro that's what I'm saying I
have drugs off me dude I've been nice to
you guys and I'm fucking going to jail
dude what the fuck is wrong with this
picture dude please dude you guys got to
fucking help me man I'm not fucking
bullshit you dude please bro all you
motherfuckers are good dudes and you're
looking here you're sit here trying to
assess am I telling the truth dude
fucking touch my hand dude touch my hand
bro ask me the
question man just touch my hand and
ask it's not but I'm in possession of
ointment bro you're in possession of
ointment test positive
marijuana sorry that's what you are in
possession of sir I'm not trying to
fucking Street the system or
anything it makes mistake man just I
know that you're 18 my mother gave my
bag bump from my dog beach and she took
it out of the can 100 times that doesn't
mean that you didn't stuff whatever you
had in the car any sir I don't do drugs
I don't stuff nothing I'm on Federal
pration and I'm not lying me scale you
your because I fucking weigh up that
fucking little fake weed from tobacco
Exotica in Daytona on International the
same thing I told him bro I buy the
little stuff that you can smoke to taste
like to try and keep myself from
relapsing and doing dumb shit I'm not
fucking up brother I'm telling you I
report the probation every fucking every
other week or every week when they call
me I do what I'm supposed to do man I
what were you in make counterfeit money
bro your call was counterfeit
money but I was on drugs bro I was doing
drugs I was fucking up man you know it
took my whole life bro I wouldn't do it
again I'm not going to lie to you you're
a fucking man bro I'm a man I'm a man
I'm I did wrong I broke the law but I'm
a man man I I'm not going to lie to you
bro I promise you man I tried to talk to
him I'm a man bro don't don't let this
happen I'm asking you as a man do the
right thing in my world I won't let you
down I got nothing nothing that word
bro bro send all that to the lab bro I
report to Federal listen list list check
this out let me ask you can't go by the
way dude you have you two inconclusive
tests no we have two very inconclusive
tests wait it's not the same jar brother
it's not fucking drugs man I swear all
my fucking
life I'm saying one says weed and then
he said it was separate test we get that
all the time we test weed all the time
that this place
is all the time we get it all the
time I don't know what else to say you
probably I'm just telling you the truth
it's not and listen understand your
position on it but there's nothing that
we can do dud you at least give me the
fucking respect cuz I've sat here with
your deputies dude please turn my phone
on me call my mother please brother and
what would you like for us to tell your
mother I want to hear my mom's voice bro
cuz it's going to be the last time I
probably can see it my mom's in bad
shape my mom is fucking in really bad
shape I don't want to talk about it know
this situation is not real you're going
to look back in this and you're say wow
dude that was a big career Mark right
there dude I'm
not God on me man you have there's no
way you don't believe me I see behind
the fucking glasses d you know I'm not
lying to you bro I know right now the
only things I know for certain are the
facts that it is tested positive marij
want like I said I'm empathetic to your
flight dude and I feel bad for you
however however that stuff got into the
seats poppy seats test
positive test positive for herin you
know the fucking a goddamn Red Bull a
Red Bull test positive for cocaine
maamin and please D help my
fucking
[Music]
put over an hour right you got to get in
the car give me a water man the
doct not going to help you you got to
have a seat in the
car please don't hurt me bro I'm
not at some point you're going to cat no
don't do that going to catch res at this
point why I'm having a m health I'm
taking freaking out cooperating we've
not I'm cooperating I need help have a
seat I sit down already once bro please
put your feet in please
dudeen put your head in the car dude I'm
not fucking doing drugs and stuff please
bro can I can I breathe bro please let
me c letting it bre keep talking you're
putting me in little small space I'm not
I told you I have airing on M to go deal
with that okay we're taking you to the
hospital they're going to get you
checked out they're going to check your
heart and make sure you're okay
you understand that but if you do not
listen and put your feet in the car and
put your head in the car you're going to
catch an additional charge am I clear
can am I clear please please please I
know pleas he's my
Superior I'm not trying to be mean bro
please I'll get in the car go the other
side of the car I'm not going to I'm not
what do you want me to do no here I'll
get out you want me to do it put me in
there bro what do you want me to do KCK
your feet kick your feet help me bro
help me bro your help me BR push push
push swing your feet you're in you're in
relax nobody's hurting
you dude yes you dude guys man look man
this is no taking to the hospital we're
taking you to the hospital we're get
checked out D can't you have somebody
check out that before you put a fucking
charge huh you hand me the seat
Bel dude why do you have to violate my
you're violating my federal probation
I'm listen everything
dude listen coming in contact with law
enforcement and having this bullshit
charge you when they drop it they're
going to send me back to prison for 10
to 14 it's this
system I
dude I didn't I didn't
oh turn to the left I can't you got my
brok turn your head to the left what you
want me to
do please don't on my please don't your
it's going to go around your stomach
around your stomach relax go nice and
loose bro I am looking you dude please
dude please dude please don't do this no
please the window down will please don't
don't hurt me man put your knee away
from the door put your knee away from
the
door all right